There's this Congressman Jim Jordan, he's
a Republican. He's prominently been featured
in the Trump impeachment inquiry hearings
because he has been one of the questioners
on the house intelligence committee for the
last seven or so days. He's sometimes referred
to as gymnasium Jordan. Sometimes he's called
gym shorts Jordan. And a lot of people don't
know why and it's actually horrible.
It's disgusting. Why? And there's now been
a lawsuit filed against Jim Jordan for legibly
ignoring allegations of abuse against, um,
a disgraced, former Ohio state university
doctor named Richard Strauss. And the story
as it's been told is that Jim Jordan, a coach
at Ohio state at the time was told about this
doctor exposing himself and masturbating in
front of people in the gym, showers after
a wrestling match. And as the lawsuit alleges,
Jim Jordan just sort of shrugged it off, didn't
report it later, denied knowing about it.
Although now it's increasingly clear and alleged
that he certainly knew about it and he didn't
do a damn thing about it. So that's the part
of this law. The lawsuit that makes Jim Jordan's
performance during the recent impeachment
inquiry hearings, particularly hypocritical
and you know the right is immune from hypocrisy.
They don't in the sense that they don't understand
that at this point where it becomes incredibly
hypocritical of Jim Jordan is that he berated
recent impeachment witness, Lieutenant Colonel
Alexandra Veneman for failing to alert the
proper authorities as Jim Jordan's side.
How can Jim Jordan, who is now being sued
over not reporting sexual abuse to the proper
authorities, how can he get away with criticizing
Veneman incorrectly, by the way, for not reporting
things that Jim Jordan believes should have
been reported. This is the epitome of someone
who is in the most shoddily constructed glass
house throwing stones. It is the height of
hypocrisy. Now, we've already talked about
the character assassination against active
duty military member, Lieutenant Colonel Alexander
Veneman. But their format was to smile and
to say thank you so much for your service.
Lieutenant Colonel Veneman or mr van Minnis,
someone referred him and then immediately
going right into character assassination.
And in Jim Jordan's case, in an extraordinarily
hypocritical way that should discussed every
single one of us. So I don't know what's going
to happen with the lawsuit. Um, I, uh, we,
we've seen at least so far, Jim Jordan, whether
this relatively well in the sense that, I
mean, okay, it hasn't blown up into a persistent
storyline in the reports of the impeachment
inquiry hearings.
Every time Jim Jordan talks. And it's actually
disappointing because there's a lot of Republicans
who, if you talk to witnesses the way Jim
Jordan talks to them, does a lot of Republicans
who don't seem to understand or care about
substance and they come away thinking, Whoa,
this guy is alpha. This guy is showing up
and he's embarrassing witnesses and he's showing
that everything is just Trump, Trump political
nonsense trumped up political nonsense. Uh,
there's a lot of people that are this out
of touch and it would be very good, I think,
to expose the stunning hypocrisy and the alleged,
uh, cover up that, uh, Jordan, uh, participated
in. If the allegations are true in not reporting
a sexual misconduct around a locker room,
it's sickening. We will see what happens with
the lawsuit and we will see what Jim Jordan's
continued role is as a a sycophantic Brown
nosing defender of Donald Trump.
We have a tremendous Friday show for you today.
Of course, we have the producer Pat Ford hosted
bonus show as a mainstay on Fridays. We also,
uh, will be taking some of your calls. I will
be answering some of your questions and remember
black Friday a week from today, everybody
on our mailing list will get an email with
a very special membership discount offer.
All you need to do to get that on Friday is
to sign up for our newsletter@davidpakman.com
let me know what you think about Jim Jordan,
the impeachment hearings, Colonel Vint, Lieutenant
Colonel Veneman and all of it. I'm on Twitter
at the Pacman quick break and then continuing
with it,